vous l'avez dit pascal roland joffé a
voulu rester très fidèle à l'histoire et
s'est notamment fait conseiller par
jean-yves pâques qui est un spécialiste
culinaire du xviie siècle on regarde
votre reportage réalisé avec jean louis
brousse faire incroyable destin que
celui de françois vatel intendant
cuisinier du prince de condé chargé
d'organiser trois jours de ce risque qui
resteront dans toutes les mémoires
roland joffé le réalisateur de michonne
de la déchirure tenait à détendre tout
autant la société du xviie que le
tragique parcours d'un homme
la demande de roland je fais était une
demande d'exactitude
donc nous n'avons pas fait de faux il
n'ya que du vrai appuyé sur les vivres
du xviie siècle sur les correspondances
sur la connaissance qu'on peut avoir du
goût et de l'apparat de cette époque là
jean yves patte connaît bien les
tableaux du xviie il est tombé dedans
quand il était petit ce passionné s'est
servi des traités culinaire de l'époque
qui parlait des recettes tout comme de
l'étiquette on a l'impression qu'il se
tenait bien à table moi l'idée que
j'avais c'était des gens qui mangeaient
salma nous on commence à manger
proprement rencontre il ya une éthique
est très très forte à la cour tout est
codifié toutes et tous s'installent
évidemment comme la cour donne le ton
tout la société va s'y mettre
et c'est au xviie siècle que l'on
connaît véritablement d'une manière plus
générale usage de la fourchette du
couteau usage des moeurs de la table
usage la propreté
on apprend ainsi que fat elle a
introduit au château de chantilly plus
sage d'une certaine crème
jean tellement parce que c'est dit c'est
une vieille recette de chantilly par la
pâture connaissait bien notre cash et se
régaler c'était en même temps un plaisir
parce qu'il venait goûter des boissons
il dégoûté des préparations musée ça tu
l'as fait trop vite ça manque de sa
bande